est ce que vous aimez les pc si vous
aimez les pc vous allez être surpris
alors peut-être que vous connaissez déjà
cette machine en pet pas celle là
exactement mais son ancêtre son
prédécesseur les modèles sortis avant
asus zen book pro 14 pouces duo version
oled ça c'est très chouette parce que
c'est une toute nouvelle type de machine
tout d'un tout nouveau type de machine
je vais faire comme ça sera plus simple
cette machine n'a renferme deux écrans
deux fois plus d'usagers beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus de choses à faire machine
super intéressante design très atypique
ça se passe bien dans ce que je veut
l'ouvrir comme ça mais surtout vous
allez voir on a 1 comment dire une
disposition qui est vraiment fait
différemment par rapport à d'autres
ordinateurs avec un espace qui est
vraiment concentré une partie avec un
écran supérieur ici un clavier très
concentré un tout petit trackpad si bien
que cette machine elle peut-être pas
fait pour vous mais elle est peut-être
aussi fait pour vous derrière là bas et
vous là bas donc on va regarder si cette
machine est fait pour vous si elle peut
vous intéresser et vous allez voir elle
est très surprenante très différente un
peu plus cher mais hyper canon livres
[Applaudissements]
regarder dès l'allumage ça commence là
on voit alors la dalle ici à l'abri en
temps là on est sur du brillant haut en
bas on est sur du mat on est sur du haut
l'aide de tous les côtés ces trucs à
connaître alors un écran tactile donc
ici malheureusement on va venir prendre
les traces de doigts un petit peu mamba
quoique un petit peu mais un petit peu
moins sur le haut les traces de doigts
tout de suite ça va être un peu plus ça
après vous venez que petit chiffonnette
et ça ira alors comme police ali tactile
up l'attaquent on se connecte on ouvre
ses biens alors là je vous ai mis plein
de trucs donc je vais déjà à venir
fermer un peu tout ça ça se présente
comme ça c'est à dire j'ai un très grand
écran au ces un écran 14,5 pouces écran
2 8 4 2880 par mille 800 pixels séduit
lars un ratio un peu différent c'est du
16 10e ont connu le 16/9 ça c'est du 16
10e mais bon voilà ça conviendra très
très très bien surtout ici on a un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz à 0,2
millisecondes beaucoup de sunnites et
s'ils voulaient venir jouer à des jeux
derrière vous de la performance on va
regarder ça dans quelques instants un
d'écran certifié pantone donc des
couleurs qui sont réelles 100% dci p3 un
contraste infini parce qu'on est sur un
écran oled a que des noirs profonds
trous hdr black 501 milliard de couleurs
est ce un écran qui ici est certifié
lutter contre la lumière bleue parts of
green landais et qui est également
certifié anti flickr vous savez anti
scintillement ski à fatiguer les yeux
donc ça c'est cool et ça c'est l'écran
du haut l'écran du bas il est juste là
alors il est tout autant un peu grand
c'est le scream pas de +12 7 pouces 2880
ben oui on a la même largeur fatalement
par 864 pixels ici c'est pas du hall est
c'est une dalle épaisse 120 air son
niveau le taux de rafraîchissement
également anti reflets vous l'avez vu
100% dci p3 et dans un cas comme dans
l'autre on est 100 du 510 voilà la
terrre voilà l'idée voilà quoi ça
ressemble alors vous dirai ça c'est bien
beau mais qu'est ce que en réalité je
vais venir faire d'un ordinateur avec un
premier écran là et un deuxième écran la
deuxième écran vous le voyez en plus on
est légèrement surélevé alors légèrement
surélevé il ya un intérêt c'est pour la
dissipation thermique ça permet qu'il ya
un système de ventilation qui fait
sortir et leur part les côtés c'est là
on est un angle de 12 degrés je crois
maximum ici l'a envoyé au niveau de
l'inclinaison alors ça c'est pas mal en
fait parce que voyez lorsque vous
l'ouvrez vraiment comme ça l'air va
sortir par là on va aussi ventilé parle
de sous on ventile par tous les côtés ça
permet d'avoir une bonne dissipation
thermique et on évite d'avoir une
machine qui chauffe autres choses à
connaître ici c'est une machine qui est
une certification militaire alors je
vous dis pas ce que je fais partie par
coeur c'est la mil std 810f vous m'en
direz tant permis d'avoir des preuves
avec les hautes températures les basses
températures contre l'humidité également
contre les chutes on va pas être jetés
pour autant il va résister en altitude
et également contre les vibrations
voiliers qui ont bien bougé un peu comme
ça s'il ya des vibrations bon ça bouge
ça va il est certifié résistance assez
bien alors par contre ici il ya une
seule couleur cellatex black et j'aime
beaucoup parce que l'orge pas si vous
allez voir on retrouve un petit sorte
d'anneau que fabrique a su s'ajuster
plutôt comme ça vous partez de lasser
des anneaux concentriques qui partait
qui s'élargissent jusque là jusque là
jusque là il ya même un petit truc qui
viennent le marquage ce et les petites
finitions mais elles sont sympas asus
zenbook qui est écrit sur le devant
alors premiers trucs à savoir si c'est
que ces machines qui est très très fine
pour autant ce n'était pas le pc le plus
fin au monde mais vu comment elle est
fait et vu les deux écrans je puis vous
assurer qu'elle est très très fine elle
fait en plus un kilo 75 aller assez
légère donc on a une machine qu'on peut
venir emmener partout avec soi et par
rapport aux anciennes générations sauf
que l'asus a vraiment fait un très très
beau travail au niveau de la finesse au
niveau de la légèreté au niveau de la
portabilité du produit autre truc qui
est intéressant à savoir c'est ce qu'on
va voir au niveau de la connectique
alors vous allez voir c'est très drôle
ce qu'ils ont fait ici aussi sur le côté
gauche vous avez ici des sorties d'air
et une prise jack et jack micro pour
venir à communiquer si vous sautez jake
moore et compagnie vous avez bien
évidemment des prises de côté on va
avoir deux prises usb c'est somnambule 4
qui serviront aussi bien débrancher un
moniteur qu'à venir recharger si vous
souhaitez vous avez en plus une prise
ici usb à hockey plutôt bien et ce qui
est marrant c'est qu'ils sont venus
mettre des prises derrière c'est plutôt
atypique et plus tu auras alors vous
avez un hdmi 2.5 est située juste là
vous avez un lecteur de cartes microsd
qui est situé derrière plus trop bien
mais assez rare et vous avez également
ici le contraire brancher votre bloc
d'alimentation qui est lui assez costaud
bon c'est un bloc d'alim pc un peu
standard dont vous pouvez me reçoit le
recharger comme ça hop là si vous voulez
et si vous voulez acheter l adaptateur
compatible je dirais du pouvoir délivrer
mais je peux pas vous dire de bêtises
vous venez de brancher ici en usb c'est
ça c'est très pratique c'est assez
marrant parce qu'en fait en règle
générale les ports et son de chaque côté
mais je pense qu'il ya un travail en
fait ils ont eu un problème au niveau de
l'espace et il a fallu me repousse un
peu les murs parce que fatalement sur
cette machine et bien il y en a de tous
les côtés que ce soit du côté que vous
allez voir mais également de l'intérieur
donc il a fallu à un moment faire des
choix bon moi ça me dérange pas le fait
d'avoir du hdmi derrière pour me
débrancher un moniteur se pose aucun
problème vu que je vais arriver par
derrière le lecteur de cartes peut être
on va se dire regardez dans la machine
je fais le tour j'ai ma carte bon ok par
contre vous avez bien de l'usbc de côté
vous avez bien la prise jack là bon ça
me va autre élément qui est vraiment
très important et je vous le dit tout à
l'heure en préambule c'est à dire que
comme aussi on vient peut pousser les
murs fatalement il faut faire des choix
il faut resserrer au niveau du clavier
et le trackpad est tout petit si vous
avez l'habitude d'aller trackpad un peu
grand ou si vous voulez un trackpad un
peu grand très clairement c'est pas du
tout à un ordinateur qui est fait pour
vous ici c'est un petit très peu
d'erreurs tout ça je vous le dis
honnêtement ça reste une question
d'habitude vous allez prendre l'habitude
de venir l'utiliser comme ça le clavier
s'avance y fait très rapidement les
touches sont légèrement incurvé pour une
question de confort aux niveaux au
niveau de la frappe vous avez retrouvé à
peu près toutes les touches dont vous
avez besoin il ya des touches en plus
qui existent ici pour bien switcher de
l'écran du haut vers l'écran du bas
alors je vais vous ouvrir un truc sur
l'écran du haut on va se mettre par
exemple un petit microsoft days la gare
des voiliers typiquement la gym on doit
qui dérape chercher des flèches alors
que au pelage suis pas encore assez
habitué je pense avec le petit bouton la
halle celui-là vous venez switch est
donc là ce que je fais c'est xsapi
dessus et hop ce qui étend aux passants
bas et ce qui est en bas passant au ca
évident de venir faire parce qu'après on
peut venir le faire avec ses doigts je
vais vous montrer il ya un autre truc
c'est que vous prenez votre fenêtre
alors attendez je suis pas encore et
vous l'achetez au nos voyages est pas
aussi brillant sonnette et vous
l'achetez au vous l'achetez en eau et je
suis pas le champion du je me fais trop
mais en fait c'est comme ça que ça
marche donc je prends hop et je jette
donc après vous avez un système lorsque
vous êtes là la regarder et vous menant
ils vous demandent sans qu'à l'écran
voulu aller le train c'est celui-là le 2
c'est l'autre et là c'est passer en
plein écran vous mettez sur le 2 par
exemple là il arrive en bas et alors
autres choses à venir connaître c'est la
même chose en bas vous prenez bien votre
fenêtre là vous la mettez sur l'écran et
après les vous mais un truc regarder ça
c'est vachement intéressant lorsque vous
êtes là il vous demande si vous voulez
le mettre partagez votre écran en quatre
ateliers votre écran en deux à la
verticale ou à l'horizontale pour venir
faire du multitâche comme ça après vous
pouvez venir vraiment l'adapter pour le
multitâche parce que l'intérêt d'avoir
un très grand écran comme ça c'est de
faire du multitâche c'est vraiment un
truc qui va vous servir donc soit on
peut le faire comme ça donc là hop là il
est partagé à l'émoi sais pas ce qui
m'intéresse qui va m'intéresser on va
dire c'est le maître en très grand donc
là je me positionne hélas après je peux
venir et tendre jusqu'en bas lorsque
vous êtes là vous le mettez comme ça et
là ce qui est pratique c'est qu'en fait
ça vous fait un seul et même grand écran
pour venir lire vos news dont vous voyez
ça c'est extrêmement pratique parce que
effectivement on a installé rennes au
grand écran alors ça c'est marrant parce
que c'est un usage principal on peut se
dire ok je peux venir regarder mais j'ai
quand même une coupure centre il ya
d'autres façons je vous le dit bien
partagé l'écran en deux ans trois ans
qu'à deux mètres en haut de mettre en
bas on peut déplacer on a compris
l'intérêt du multitâche maintenant c'est
des fois un peu rébarbatif vous dites
par exemple tiens moi dans mon process
de travail je veux en haut un excellent
je veux en bas une calculatrice je veux
à côté j'en sais rien moi une prise de
notes joue pour naviguer sur internet il
va en fait vous venez enregistré tout ça
directement ça c'est vachement cool
s'envolent ce crime pas de plus vous
avez plein de petites options qui sont
là d'abord la luminosité ok on peut la
pousser pas trop ça ça me va bien ici
gardez ça me propose mes différentes
fenêtres qu'est ce que je veux m ou 6 et
ça bon ok ça marche ensuite on revient
ici là je vais switcher du haut vers le
bas comme je peux le faire avec mon
petit bouton physique tout en sachant et
j'ai parié jusqu'au bout de terre ma
démo vous avez ce bouton là qui va venir
désactiver l'écran du bas qui vous donne
des options en fait activé le screen pas
de plus assombrir le screen pas de plus
d activer skin pack plus pour moi je
veux qu'il soit activée donc je reste
dessus comme ça si on a besoin que de la
partie du haut ça évite de venir taper
la batterie pour la partie du bas ça
dépend de vos usages à un instant t
alors on revient ici sans notre screen
pas de plus j'appuie là je viens
désactiver my web cam et j'appuie la
junte désactiver aurait activé mon micro
et c'est justement en dessous que ça
devient vachement intéressante parce que
si j'appuie la chaleur des raccourcis
leurs différentes applications par
exemple spotify hop je clique ici j'ai
spotify qui va venir se lancer spotify
il arrive en bas pratique autre truc qui
vachement intéressant voyez j'ai plein
de potes des applications je peux venir
en rajouter également si je le souhaite
pour avoir des raccourcis ici à
boudouaou à bout de stylet et on en
parle dans quel sens ça c'est très
pratique mais après tout pouvait venir
créer des scénarios de travail dé taipei
jusqu'à 4 que je vois ici groupe de
travail numéro un je vois j'ai dû world
gets navigateur internet une
calculatrice g de l'excellent sur le 2
avec le gestionnaire de fichiers et
disney + loach est un vrai foyer donc ça
me crée d'une configuration alors
regardez on va appuyer sur le 1 je vous
montre ce qui se passe alors ça c'est
pas nouveau ça existait déjà avant mais
ça reste extrêmement pratique et c'est
tout l'adn de cette machine ça m'ouvre
un world en eau alors world que j'ai pas
activer cette machine donc je sens et ça
mais je vous ouvre des petits trucs pour
vous montrer donc en haut là j'ai dû
voir de grands classiques je peux venir
travailler édité avec mon doigt ou avec
mon style est en bas je vais avoir mon
navigateur internet parce qu'en même
temps que travaille sur mon ward j'ai
besoin de faire des recherches et puis
là j'ai une calculatrice où je vais
pouvoir venir faire des calculs par
exemple pas tiens je veux travailler
j'en sais rien j'ai si j'ai ça ça c'est
le premier scénario mais si j'en veux un
autre c'est qu'à venir appuyer ici
groupe de taches numéro 2 ça nourrir de
nouvelles applications par dessus je
vais avoir ici un excellent que j'ai
choisi de m g en dessous mon explorateur
de fichiers et à côté j'ai mis 10 n'est
plus parce que lorsque je regarde mes
comptes ou que je travaille sur un
tableur excel j'aime bien mettre un
petit marvel à côté chacun fait comme il
veut ensuite je vais avoir un autre avec
je dis bon allez c'est bon j'ai bien
bossé je ne mets 10 n'est plus sur le
haut directement et je me dis que en bas
âge et pouvoir regarder ce navigue un
peu sur internet en faisant bâtir en
même temps je pouvoir bosser un peu mais
je calme suite principalement mon fils
ou ma série ici et puis un petit bloc
parce que j'ai quand même prendre sur ce
que je suis en train de faire là enfin
c'est bien et puis dernier cas d'usagé
je me suis dit bon bah là j'ai vraiment
partager un peu en quatre jeux mais d'à
côté du world je mets les côtés mon
navigateur je mets un petit solitaire
parce que j'ai envie de me marrer et de
jouer au carré en même temps je mets une
petite souris parce que j'ai le cerveau
qui partent tous les côtés je regarde
des milliers de trucs donc ça voyez je
peux le faire cette manière on trouve ça
intéressant pour venir paramétrer très
facilement après l'inconvénient c'est
que tout est encore ouvert donc il faut
venir le faire mais directement donc je
prends mes petits doigts et je faire des
choses mais l'idée vachement sympa parce
que si vous voulez dans un process de
travail ça évite de se dire en
permanence tient faut jamais ouvrir je
mets en place je fais si je fais ça j'ai
pas envie de m'embêter et mon pc va
gérer ça directement et automatiquement
pour moi donc ça c'est cool et puis
ensuite
des petits paramètres juste en bas là où
je pouvais revenir régler à lormont
d'affichage voyait affichage de mon
script pas de plus le minot dit
arrière-plan le thème je peux dire tout
juste aux mises et donc ça c'est cool la
résolution car déjà la luminosité
l'arrière plan le thème sont ré
compagnie csa centre de contrôle je peux
venir le personnaliser un truc
intéressant c'est link marque asus je
peux venir le link est un téléphone pour
voir passer mes coups de fil directement
depuis mon ordinateur pourquoi pas que
je vais avoir aussi contrôle de la
fenêtre sculptures de l'application cox
peut venir paramétrer pas mal de petites
choses quand même l'économie d'énergie
bon la version du logiciel ici donc je
trouve ça vachement intéressant une fois
de plus dans l'idée de venir tout piloté
comme ça alors ça c'est un truc un peu
de base on a du multi fenêtres du
multitâche d'un côté et de l'autre mais
ça ne s'arrête pas ça serait un peu trop
mais il ya notre qui vachement bien je
vais vous montrer par exemple avec
lightroom lightroom olemps photoshop
j'ai mon photoshop là qu'est ce que ça
va faire seulement photoshop et bien ça
m'ouvre en outils de contrôle juste en
bas c'est pareil ça existait déjà
l'année dernière où l'ag pouvoir venir
travailler alors je prends mon style est
mais je peux le faire aller qu'autre
chose voyez par exemple si je veux dire
retouché ma photo je peux venir par
exemple ici me prendre un outil crayon
dans mon outil crayon et bien au plat je
viens me dessiner autour des yeux m'a
miné extrêmement fine or il faut savoir
qu'avec le nom du style exact parce que
chaque marque à son nom c'est la zus
peine 2.0 vous avez 4000
interchangeables rendez vous ouvrez ici
vous venez le charger juste l'un donc
vous le brancher directement dans votre
pc ici on l'usbc vous avez le petit
câble usb c'est vers usb à de l'autre
côté danse est très pratique et en plus
de ça vous avez deux boutons d pouvant
venir utiliser différemment pour venir
travailler pour venir gommer pour venir
édité par faire ce que vous voulez donc
c'est quand même vachement pratique
voyez va c'est un outil pour venir
effacés la séquelle outils je vais
choisir l'épaisseur de mon crayon donc
je peux augmenter l'épaisseur et à
prévoyez tu peux me faire des lunettes
un peu plus grosse un peu plus cool donc
ça c'est rigolo et après je peux venir
annuler mes actions par exemple la
partie du bassin petit bouton annuler sa
annuler ce que je viens de faire donc ce
truc là il vachement cool parce qu'en
fait c'est un petit raccourci qui me
servira réellement lorsque je veux venir
bosser là je peux venir gérer par
exemple la taille de mon pinceau à
mettre un pinceau qui va être un peu
plus grand ou un peu plus petit je le
vois ça ne les crises il a regardé voyez
taille du pinceau donc ça c'est pareil
c'est un truc tout bête mais c'est quand
même
vachement pratique du pouvoir retrouver
là je vais avoir également un zoom avant
arrière sur le calque donc je peux venir
désolé je peux venir sous meymont kalt
le flux du pinceau donc la voyez j'ai
plein de petits outils qui sont très
très cool et que ce pouvoir venir
utiliser directement pour faute aux
chiens tout en sachant que lorsque
j'appuie ici j'avais retrouvé mon
control panel sur vaud où je vous vois
renier ensuite modifié j'ai d'autres
outils qui sont en bas et je vais
pouvoir me recule stomisés mon control
panel parce qu'en fait ces différents
espaces dans lequel jamais des outils
qui seront plus ou moins gros donc le
truc est vachement bien fait alors ça ça
fonctionne sur photoshop lightroom
classique qui est là ça fonctionne pas
sur lightroom ça prouve que sur
lightroom classique after effects
premiere pro et vous avez illustrator
donc ça va être du hadopi mais ce truc
là est vachement bien d'envoyer sa
montre une fois de plus les usages nous
on peut aller donc là je voulais montrer
effectivement avec photoshop on peut
s'ouvrir un petit lightroom classique ça
s'ouvre directement avec des outils qui
sont complètement dédié ici à itron
classique donc s'écouler de la même
manière lorsque vous voulez faire un
montage vidéo sur premiere pro et bien
vous pouvez mettre en bas une timeline
naviguer dans votre timeline directement
donc c'est vraiment un outil qui est
extrêmement pratique donc au delà du
côté un peu gadget multitâche très
grandes fenêtres pour venir à naviguer
ou regarder un film pendant que vous
bossez et bien il ya vraiment un outil
qui va vous servir à la productivité à
la créativité est en fait c'est
vachement intéressant parce que avec vos
screen pas de plus avec votre outil avec
votre écran principal sur le haut et
avec votre stylet et bien vous avez un
super combos pour bien faire plein de
choses en terme de création donc ça
c'est vachement bien donc cet ordinateur
il est vachement intéressant pour
différents types de personnes si vous
êtes créatif ve vous avez tue pas vous
faites de la vidéo pourrait venir
décharger ici directement votre carte
microsd sinon vous venez branchez-vous
prochain petit aubin ici on us blessés
ou en usb à voulait faire de l'édition
photos du montage vidéo pourrait faire
du code si vous êtes codeurs ça nous
fait aussi un super grand écran pour
venir travailler très facilement enfin
bref c'est une vraie boîte à outils dont
ça c'est vachement pratique pour tous
ces métiers là s'est pas laissée serment
l'ordinateur que je le recommande est
uniquement pour le côté bureautique
familiale divertissement parce qu'il est
quand même assez cher on commence à 2299
99 dans une version qui pas très très
énorme en termes de ram et compagnie
mais je vous déteste dans quelques
instants donc c'est pas une machine qui
est dédié monsieur madame tout le monde
sauf si vous avez beaucoup d'argent et
vous faire très plaisir sinon je pense
pas que ce soit la machine qu'il vous
faudrait bien acheté ça c'est vraiment
la machine pour les créatifs tout en
sachant qu'en plus à l'intérieur vous
avez 2 confie que vous êtes sur un intel
core de deuxième génération vous avez
soit un i7 soit 1,9 certifiés et vaut
donc ça c'est plutôt bien côté graphique
on a une italie 6 e de base très
honnêtement pour venir faire du montage
vidéo je vous recommande pas ça vous
avez également la possibilité d'avoir
une nvidia c'est une geforce rtx 30 50
pays donc c'est ce que je vous
recommande un minime 1 pour tout ce qui
va être création vidéo ina vous faut ça
très clairement avec 4 gigas de ram
dédiée ce et la ddr 6 vous avez soit 16
soit 32 gigas de ram dans votre machine
c'est la lp2 dire 5 ok très bien et vous
avez soit 512 go de stockage soit 1 tera
soit 2 tera en ssd ya ce qu'il faut
alors après vous irez jeter un oeil
parce que je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description mais notamment
sylvain sur le site d'asus à l'instant
au jour même où je fais cette vidéo on
ne propose uniquement la config avec un
i7 16 giga de ram et une intel iris xx e
et un terrain de stockage j'ai pas du
tout la version avec le nvidia j'ai pas
la version avec le line up j'ai pas les
32 gigas de ram j'ai pas les deux
terrains de stockage est ce que c'est
une exclu qu'ils gardent pour un autre
revendeur je suis pas convaincu est ce
que c'est un problème de composants
qu'ils n'auraient pas et que ça va
décaler des choses peut-être en tout cas
la version i 7 16 intel est 6e et un
terrain on est à 2299 avec 99 c'est
quand même très élevé mais c'est une
machine très atypique et très sympa ici
on a une batterie de 76 watts/heure asus
nous annonce 9h30 d'autonomie ça va
dépendre de vous de l'activité que vous
allez en faire c'est une activité mixte
si vous êtes beaucoup sur le screen pas
de plus en bas ou alors s'il est tout le
temps désactiver ça va dépendre vraiment
parce que une machine comme ça si vous
mettez un première pro qui va tourner et
que vous utiliser à fond avec de la
luminosité maximale le scream pas de
plus 9h30 vous pouvez toujours rêver
vous avez beaucoup plus bas maintenant
si vous travaillez sur de la bureautique
pas tout le temps avec le screen pas de
plus mais de temps en temps ça va aller
on va monter on va gagner que ça va
vraiment dépendre de vous de vos usages
de ce que vous allez en faire d'autres
trucs à connaître ici est bien c'est que
on est et vous le voyez sur un windows
alors windows on en a déjà parlé j'ai
déjà fait une vidéo dessus que je vous
invite à venir voir windows on est
intéressant il ya plein de bénéfices
d'intérêts pour venir passer sur windows
ondes je vous mets le lien quelque part
en bas ou sinon allez jeter un coup
d'oeil sur ma chaîne pour vous de
découvrir cette fameuse vidéo de
présentation de windows
reparti et l'audio alors ici on a un son
qui est fait en partenariat notamment
avec harman kardon
[Musique]
vous entendez ou pas
il ya un petit côté qui pompent en fait
ça monte à 3,1
le son est très médium en fait pour moi
le son et si c'est pas la qualité
principale de cette machine si vous
voulez venir vous travaillez en édition
montage bosser avec un casque priziac
bluetooth mais comme il est là où la
qualité c'est très dur
[Musique]
paypal
ok ok donc voilà c'est le truc un peu
moyen bon ok on peut pas être très bon
partout on n'a pas une très grande
spécialisation on n'a pas un très grand
spectre audio ça fait le taff pas plus
pas moins autre élément à bien connaître
vous avez une webcam c'est du 720p
pourquoi ne pas avoir mis du 1080p
pourquoi ne peut pas filmer en 1080p sur
un ordinateur qui nous coûte un peu plus
de 2000 euros fin c'est un peu dommage
j'aurais vraiment aimé pouvoir avoir
effectivement une caméra avec une
qualité un peu à regret d un peu
supérieure après elle fonctionne avec de
l'infrarouge windows et l'eau pour venir
déverrouille façon sécurisée votre
machine donc ça c'est plutôt bien mais
voilà c'est dommage très dommage un
clavier qui vient évidemment totalement
rétro éclairé revêtement anti traces de
doigts au niveau de votre trackpad et
c'est un ordinateur qui a dû où il fait
si ce donc si vous avez une box wifi 6e
ou d'une moto sans wifi 6e ça ira très
bien pour conclure un petit peu sur cet
ordinateur qu est ce qu il faut savoir
qu est ce qu il faut se dire eh bien les
usa c'est ce que je vous ai décrit ce
n'est pas un ordinateur qui est fait
pour tout le monde ça ordinateur qui va
être faite jeudi pour des gens qui ont
des besoins de création qui ont besoin
d'un deuxième écran qui ne veulent pas
avoir un moniteur cite par exemple vous
êtes en déplacement et bien vous avez
une machine qui est fine qui est un très
bel dans un sac et qui si vous avez
besoin d'un deuxième écran et bien vous
avez toujours en deuxième écran avec
vous si par exemple vous êtes streamer
alors il faut une caméra au delà parce
que moi parce trinec la webcam de toute
façon ce tribunal n'a qu'une webcam
jamais c'est interdit par le code du
streaming la cemac viennent d'inventer
donc ça on le sait pas mais par contre
j'ai le streamer vous êtes d humeur
surtout il faut avoir votre jeu ici
pouvait en bas voir le chat et puis voir
votre votre tronche en retour moniteur
donc ya pas mal de petites options va il
ya plein de choses en fait ce qui est
intéressant est formateur c'est que
c'est vous qui venez créer lusage c'est
vous qui venez vraiment le prendre en
main et faire ce que vous voulez comme
vous voulez donc là c'est très très
chouette donc une fois de plus créatif
streamer pourquoi pas codeurs lightroom
heures photoshopper et puis les
technophiles ceux qui aiment les
ordinateurs un peu à part qu'ils ont les
moyens de mettre plus de 2000 euros sur
une bécane dans la version de base
attention si vous montez en 32 gigas de
ram si vous montez en deux terrains de
stockage il vous passez sur rue du rtx1
est un peu plus cher mais voilà il faut
voir les besoins il faut tout
rationaliser wazemmes bien il faut s'y
faire moi j'ai l'habitude ne traque pas
de là j'arrive là je fais waouh c'est
pas très grand quand même hein c'est
petit je suis vite fait là mais après
bon on s'y habitue on lève le doigt on
est en place le fait d'avoir aussi le
stylet ça peut être intéressant que
j'utilise pas de style et au quotidien
c'est pas mon truc mais si vous c'est
votre truc et bien vous avez un style et
qui marche 4086 points de pression aux
très grands classiques bon et voilà donc
bon ça fonctionne c'est bien c'est une
belle machine je ne sais pas si vous
vous arriverez à vous projeter avec vous
leur dites moi quels seraient vos usages
et qu'est ce que vous en feriez marquer
ça en bas en commentaire moi je vais la
recommander mais pas pour tout le monde
pour ceux qui se disent qu'ils ont
besoin de puissance de performance
qu'ont besoin d'ordinateur un peu
atypique et qui aime bien les machines
un peu différente elle un peu bruyante
aussi attention ce que lorsqu'elle se
refroidit écoutez là on l'entend il ya
des ventilateurs c'est pas la machine la
moins silencieuse de bon il faut
ventiler l'histoire et le bouzin
n'oublie pas ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire si elle vous
intéresse bien évidemment je voulais un
lien en bas dans la description et puis
nous on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech d'ordinateurs de
smartphones d'asus et de plein d'autres
marques c'est plein de choses à raconter
et ça c'est chouette vous embrasse pour
lé soin de vous et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]